foreign
Alabama let's save Joe's question for a
future episode because we have a
question here from Instagram Rachel has
something for us how do you distinguish
just in case items for just for when
items when it comes to packing GO bags
go you know what's funny so yeah the go
bag it all depends on where you live at
I feel like because when we lived in
Montana we had to be prepared for very
different things than living here in
Southern California so in Montana uh in
the winter time you're preparing with
chains you're preparing with emergency
blankets maybe a little bit of food
where in California you're preparing for
potential you know earthquakes that are
going to knock out the power grid and
you got to go somewhere so I mean that's
I think the first thing to consider is
where do you live and what are you
preparing for you'll hear me in Ryan and
TK talk about just in case items and
just in case being the three most
dangerous words in the English language
because they encourage us they don't
just give us permission but just in case
sounds virtuous I'll hold on to this
just in case and so let's make a
distinction real quick we have something
called the minimalist rule book 16 rules
for living with less and three of those
rules are applicable here I want to make
a distinction the first one is just in
case items anything I'm holding on to
just in case I can get rid of because
I'm not using it and I can replace it
for less than twenty dollars in less
than 20 minutes from wherever I am that
rule has worked for us a hundred percent
of the time our theory is it works 99 of
the time but it gives you permission to
let go of tens of thousands of just in
case items just for when items are
things that we purchase often
consumables that we purchase over a
period of time we know we're going to
use it within a period of time but it
may not fit into some of our other rules
the seasonality rule or whatever and so
because I don't buy my toilet paper or
my shampoo one
square at a time or one drop at a time
respectively I buy in bulk right I buy
enough that I can store it but I know
that I'm going to use it I'm buying it
just for when I need it however there's
this third category emergency items yeah
now what is an emergency item a true
emergency item is an actual just in case
item that I hope I never have to use
yeah so it's the inverse of the story We
Tell ourselves about a just in case item
I'm going to hold on to this just in
case I might need it someday I hope I
have to use this someday no no no
emergency items are I'm gonna have this
but I hope I never have to use it jumper
cables right yeah first aid kit I have
in my car I have almost nothing in my
car I have a first aid kit there I hope
I never have to use it although I have
had to use it before usually when my
daughter Cuts or scrapes or Falls
there's some sort of band-aid and
antiseptic wipes and and different
things there that I can have just for an
emergency right the chains when you're
in Montana so yes it does have to do
with the location that you live in also
your needs also the story you tell
yourself because yes you can try to
prepare for everything but if that prep
preparation is weighing you down then
those preparation items are getting in
the way you talk about a go bag because
we did a whole episode I'll put a link
to it in the show notes yeah it was a
good one about emergency items yeah
right and what Ryan I thought each of us
have a go bag in our homes which is an
emergency item if within 30 seconds I
have to leave my house and grab just one
thing it is that go bag and so it has
the essentials which you Ryan and I
talked about in depth in that episode so
I'm not going to go through them again
but understanding that I hope I never
have to grab that bag there are no just
for win items in there there are some
emergency items that I'm holding on to
just in case the absolute worst case
scenario happens and there's a boundary
it's the size of the bag right it cannot
extend beyond that boundary yeah you
know the Sinister thing about just in
case is that it can apply to anything I
mean is there anything out there for
which there is no hypothetical scenario
where you might possibly need it yeah
hold on to these notes because uh
there's a good back and I might need
some scrap paper later well they might
go into the Medalist Museum someday or
hey I don't like that kind of food but
hey if it's the last thing on Earth and
I need it to survive I'm gonna eat it so
maybe I should keep it around just in
case whenever you find yourself thinking
in terms of just in case you've got to
give yourself a set of conditions that
you're willing to be held accountable to
when am I willing to say no to the just
in case line of reasoning because you
could literally go into a store any
store and find a just in case scenario
that can motivate you to buy that thing
of course that's why all those things
are in the store just in case someone
needs to purchase them to use them
let the grocery store the retail store
hold all the justices now you have
access to them when you need them yeah
that's a good one no that the go bag I
mean again it what are you preparing to
go from or go to like if you are uh
literally need a bag to get to your
in-laws house who is you know 30 minutes
away and um you run out of gas and you
need to walk that I mean getting clear
on where you're going to like that's
going to help you prepare for the go bag
but going back to your location I mean a
go bag in Montana is a very different go
bag than Los Angeles if you enjoy this
Standalone patreon highlight if so you
can listen to full episodes of the
minimalists private podcast available
exclusively on patreon visit patreon.com
the minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and YouTube Channel 100
advertisement free